of course it's been a tough year so we
hope that
mom is close in some way somehow today
very happy mother's day to my mom and of
course my wife as well
i'd like to say the same thing all of
our moms in our lives my wife marcy and
our four kids i know it's a big day at
our house we love mom and we love all of
you
marlin's moms as well sandy who's making
his eighth start this year that
surpasses his
total from the shortened 2020 season but
a
295 era this year 298 over his last 14.
quickly 0-2 to tyrone taylor wow
what a pitch from sandy gets a strikeout
and works a 1-2-3
first brett anderson ready to go he
likes to work fast and he is anxious to
get this start started tonight
and there's a strikeout to start it for
brett anderson
their fourth consecutive strikeout for
rojas the home run in the first and
three strikeouts last night
when corbin burns returns and he is
expected to come back
on the next home stand and that's an out
at first vogelbeck makes a
diving play dickerson had nowhere to go
he's standing
at the bag he thinks he was safe
and a pretty good move he was taken off
pretty close he was stealing a base he
got picked off
good throw let's see do they get him
i think he's out i don't think there's
enough to overturn that yeah they won't
challenge too risky for don mattingly
this early
so anderson wipes out the base runner
faces three batters
in the first two and two
on the way is hitting the air out toward
left field
back goes dickerson in front of the
track makes the catch
sandy gets through the second scoreless
we've had great success away from
american family field
and be nice to return to the favor to
the marlins who won a series in
milwaukee as
anderson strikes out anderson and
anderson
called it that way
[Applause]
and they don't even have their quote
unquote best catcher omar narvaez their
offensive threat on the il that's a
dribbler
left side of the infield brinson's going
to beat it out an infield single with
two strikes just put the ball in play
you're hoping for sweet lou we talked
about missing a couple of ball games but
was starting to really swing the bat
better oh and to the count on leone
on the ground routine for wong
so anderson works around an infield hit
and a hit batter
marlin strand two measures in place a
very
thoughtful gesture from the marlins oh
there's no question about it this one
grounded to the right side diaz spins
they get
one and they get two the pitcher brett
anderson running may have given miggy
just enough time to
flip that double play well nicely done
by sandy is a good pitch
to anderson he went he was way out in
front of it
voxburger still warming with purpose in
the bullpen
could be anderson's last hitter we'll
see 3-2 pitch and he got him he fires
the bat
full badly and brett anderson with a
strikeout to end the inning
daniel vogelback leads off go back
bounced out his first time up hits a
rocket down the right field line it is
gone
daniel vogel back a frozen rope out of
here
his third home run and the brewers have
a one to nothing lead
on a rocket to right that had some hit
speed on it
how about that a 97 mile an hour
fastball in on his hands and he's able
to turn it around not just that but keep
it fair
out to center field brinson in his
tracks
sandy needs to make the pitch and does
leaves him loaded
but the vogelback homer gives the
brewers a one-nothing lead
voxburger having a hard time putting
leona away another 3-2
and a swing at a miss got him with a
changeup
nasty change voxburger
leaves two brewers lead one nothing
mentioning cabrera on friday past babe
ruth
on the hits list of course marlin's fans
recall his first
hit that's knocked down by wong
and rojas is aboard
first hit of the ball game for rojas
second quality at bat
one ball one strike and a pick at first
out at first that's what he's got
you could tell i don't know if he was
itching to run or
something an indication to the dugout
and a little over anxious and for the
second time today
a brewer pitcher picks off a runner at
first base yeah brent anderson picked
off dickerson
that's a good move by lauer to erase the
base runner
two outs nobody on three defenders right
side
outfield not too deep the pitch swung on
and missed
sandy with a strikeout and back to back
one two three
innings that brings up brian anderson
jammed him that was a cutter and darius
makes a play
how about that eric lauer putting the
marlins
middle of the order down in order with a
strikeout
two scoreless for lauer one nothing
brewers still lead
sandy alcantara is out there to face the
brewers here in the seventh
pitch is swung on and missed and that's
it for ureas
a strikeout for sandy one to nothing
brewers here teams even in hits five
aside
here's the one and two and that's over
strike three
called and kane doesn't like the call
but the inning is
over for the brewers and maylie is left
at second base
princeton's looking for his third hit
had an infield hit in the second
single down into left in the fourth
inning
brinson left center field puts a charge
in to it
oh that's off the top of the wall that's
a home run for louis bridson
and this game is tied have yourself a
day
sweet lou welcome back to the lineup my
goodness
now we have continued to talk throughout
the home stand you know some directional
hitting
with sweet luke pointing up to the
sweets mom is here that
is awesome this turns into a
big at bat with runners on the corners
in the air left field long run over for
dickerson
ranging makes the play and floro
works out of the jam we'll head to the
bottom of the eighth tied at one
marlins and brewers hooked up in a dandy
1-1 game and the brewers have their
closer on the mound
josh hader one-two pitch got him
a sweeper a breaking ball anderson
strikes out hater with his first k
one and two the count ninth inning and
he got him chased a breaking ball
melee blocks it well puts the tag on him
to secure it
made it with a couple of k's we go to
extra innings put a man
on second pogoback will be sent to first
base
you're gonna be careful with vogelback
and leave it up to tyrone taylor the
right-handed batter
anything hits the outfield grass he'll
score that ball's in the air left field
down into the gap
reyes on his way around he will score
tyrone taylor delivers in the clutch
yeah there you go
now you walk a guy in front of you two
to one brewers
as taylor comes through rasmussen a save
opportunity for the first time in the
big leagues at 25 year old
and it's a first pitch slider right off
the end of the bat wong is there
throwing a first
ball game drew rasmussen with his first
career professional save and the brewers
win on mother's day